so as we get into the spring and
eventually the summer we're going to be
talking more and more about 2022 primary
races and Midterm races and just races
in general as many of you know there's
an interesting Senate race happening in
Ohio this is the race in which JD Vance
who is the author of the book hillbilly
elegy which really wasn't a bad book but
he's gone completely off the rails JD
Vance is a candidate uh trumpist Josh
Mandel is a candidate and at a recent
debate within this race a physical fight
almost broke out which included you guys
I'm sure anybody who's been to a bar
knows these situations where two I mean
it's it's two men I've never seen women
do this at a bar they start doing the
thing where they puff up it's almost
like a peacock or you know certain
animals that kind of like there's some
frogs that like blow up their chest and
certain Birds I don't know if tit mice
do it or what kind of birds
um they kind of just start puffing
themselves up and start almost chest
bumping and it's kind of like a a battle
to see who will back down first that
which normally is that happening at bars
um took place at the Republican primary
debate it's really really wacky The
Times of Israel reporting near fight at
Ohio Republican Senate debate between
candidates Josh Mandel and Mike Gibbons
after Mandel repeatedly interrupts him
Gibbons accuses the former Soldier
of not knowing how Investments work
which was a that was a fair criticism
leading the latter to stand up and
accost his rival and we have video of
this if you're only listening you'll
have to imagine what it's like although
we'll have the clip up on our Instagram
and on our Tick Tock these are the Front
Runners guys and we'll look at polling
in a moment but this is how cartoonish
and childish and pathetic some of these
races are check this out
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you watch what happens so threats
being issued now I don't know you know
you guys will have to tell me who comes
off as the alpha male in that situation
it's
is
it's genuinely hard for me to tell and
meanwhile JD Vance who did not
participate in that but is part of this
race sat to the side thinking obviously
this really benefits me although he's
not polling that well these are the
Front Runners in the Ohio Republican
Senate primary we have the polling here
um the latest here is these are average
average
Gibbons is polling 20.
Mandel is at 18.7 so that's basically a
tie it's almost within the margin of
error JD Vance is down at 11
um and two other candidate Timken and
Dolan are almost where JD Vance is Patel
with a point and a half so that's an
interesting race and what's fascinating
about it is the least delusional people
um well I can't even say that the most
obviously delusional people are some of
the ones doing the best Mandel is an
absolute lunatic I mean just a complete
and total lunatic and if you actually go
and look at his
um political record you see that this is
uh uh just a massive massive
um pro-trump guy and uh he has backed
the election fraud claims of trump he
says that the 2020 election was stolen
he says if he wins He Will Carry forward
Trump's agenda now what's funny about
that is
it's not clear Trump really had an
agenda other than just
self-aggrandizement and and uh you know
putting himself in positions of power he
said the Trump impeachment was a sham he
will fight for the America First agenda
he says we will soon see the evidence
coming out of the widespread voter fraud
I mean that that's like a that's
verbatim What Trump says and he's tied
for first place essentially tied for
first place with Gibbons so it's a very
difficult primary
to kind of make heads or tails out of
because uh so many wacky people in there
and they don't seem to be hurt by saying
and doing crazy things we'll see if the
polling in any way is impacted if
anybody is going to benefit from that
confrontation you would think it would
be JD Vance although there might be
Republican voters who like that and you
say no I liked Gibbons before and I like
that Gibbons didn't back down or I liked
Mandel before and I liked that Mandel
didn't back down and they both puffed up
their chests at this point I don't
pretend to know what Republican voters
are going to like but we'll soon see it
reflected in the polling